[Musica]
[Applauso]
se avessi continuato a fare il pittore
sicuramente non sarei stato invitato qui
oggi perché sono qui oggi come autore e
illustratore cioè io faccio delle
immagini narranti che abitano
all'interno del libro illustrato
però quando faccio queste immagini qui
io dipingo di dipingo su carta e quando
dipingo sono come dire affamato di
qualsiasi cosa voglio e mi sento in
grado di poter immaginare qualsiasi cosa
e per dipingere faccio qualsiasi cosa
anche stare qui oggi davanti a voi
quindi non in una situazione intima che
potrebbe essere quella del mio tavolo
ma qui in piedi diciamo che ho
cominciato a fare delle immagini
assecondando anche la mia voglia di
creare dello stupore e la prima volta
che ha usato il disegno per come dire
per stupire l'altro è stato in prima
elementare
quando sono entrato in classe con dei
disegni perfettamente eseguiti con la
matita di personaggi dei cartoni animati
giapponesi che andavano allora molto in
voga tipo jeeg robot d'acciaio mazinga z
capitanarla
i miei compagni erano stupefatti si sono
chiesti ma come hai fatto fare queste
cose così in una maniera perfetta
proprio io me ne sono stato zitto e mi
sono portato a casa tutti i complimenti
del caso forse la maestra ha fatto un
ghigno capendo perfettamente il trucco
il trucco era molto semplice nel senso
che in casa mi sono trovato della carta
da lucido quella degli architetti nel
mio caso era quella di mio padre
geometra quindi messa questa carta sopra
l'album di figurine di questi personaggi
io mi sono messo lì accoppiarli
perfettamente basta questa cosa qui però
è andata avanti nel tempo perché questo
modo di fare cioè la disinvoltura che
sia quando si disegna sopra la carta da
lucido è quella che io spero sempre di
avere quando disegno senza aver nessun
riferimento come quello che sto facendo
adesso quello che sto facendo adesso non
è altro che una cartolina che vi voglio
donare poi alle scuole medie
ho incontrato entrando in classe un
professore molto alto imponente con
delle mani gigantesche che faceva dei
disegni che io fino allora non avevo mai
visto erano degli scorci di paesaggi
appunto della mia zona
di mantova e alberi oppure anche chiese
anche anche molti ritratti allora io ho
incuriosito da queste tecniche mi sono
detto beh ma forse anch'io posso farle
questi disegni e allora mi sono fatto
comprare da mio nonno dei pennelli della
carta e ho provato ad imitare lo stesso
rito che compieva questo che compiva il
mio maestro per fare quei disegni quindi
sono andato a casa e ho provato a
copiare il mio ritratto di quando ero
bimbo e non mi è venuto subito forse
dopo un po di prove però era venuto
fuori dopo un po di tentativi
all'incirca questa cosa qua che era un
mio ritratto fatto con l'inchiostro di
china
ecco sono sono andato in classe tutto
bello contento detto guardi prof che
cosa ha fatto lui guarda il disegno e
senza pietà a punta codice questo o l'ha
fatto tuo padre
o l'ha fatto tuo fratello ma non l'hai
fatto tu
ovviamente ho capito che con il disegno
e con l'arte ci si poteva far male
sono tornato a casa e dall'ultima come
dire con fila no
e appunto costavo in classe mi sono
messo in prima fila e lì dopo ho fatto
vedere che cosa ero capace di fare il
professore quando ho visto che riuscivo
a disegnare bene ecco disse a tutta la
classe così si fa e l'ha messo appeso al
muro dove c'erano tutti gli altri
disegni che dagli anni quaranta forse
erano lì ecco questa questa cosa qui mi
ha fatto capire che le persone devono
essere conquistate quando si fanno delle
immagini e io le immagini le ho imparate
a fare su un tavolo a forza di dai e dai
ea forza di dai e dai o forse capito che
la mia tecnica era quella a base di
acqua
qualcuno la chiama da può chiamare
acquarello altri la persona dire
semplicemente che si usa il medium
dell'acqua per fare anche tecniche a
base di inchiostri somma
io uso l'acquarello ecco e l'acqua e con
l'acqua non si sa mai con l'acqua tutto
può espandersi e possono venire fuori
delle immagini che non erano proprio
quelle che si avevano anche in mente e
quando io provo a dipingere qualsiasi
soggetto che potrebbe essere una
bicicletta con cagnolino un gatto un
paesaggio un albero non voglio solo
rappresentare questo oggetto io devo
essere quel soggetto quindi se faccio un
cielo
devo essere cielo mentre lo sto facendo
se faccio un cavallo sulla spiaggia
devo essere quel cavallo e così via
ovviamente la mia tecnica spesso e
volentieri non include la traccia prima
non disegno come vedete do delle
pennellate che messe assieme dovrebbero
si spera portare ad un risultato certo
io ho avuto molte influenze
il pittore più influente nella mia vita
è stato willy il coyote si willy coyote
che ad un certo punto nel bel mezzo del
grand canyon tira fuori cavalletto ai
colori e dipinge straordinari tromp
l'oeil per ingannare lo struzzo bip bip
quindi lui dipinge per necessità e ho
capito nel tempo che la pittura che mi
interessa l'arte che mi interessa in
tutte le discipline è quella necessaria
quindi willy coyote mi ha insegnato
questo wile il coyote mi ha anche
insegnato che si deve e si può dipingere
in fretta e la fretta come dice il
saggio non è buona cosa a meno che non
fai appunto e quel gesto dell'atleta cc
centometrista che per forza deve essere
molto veloce o del tuffatore con il
triplo salto carpiato tutte queste cose
qui oppure il gesto magistrale del
mastro vetraio ecco io non faccio queste
cose qui utilizzo l'acqua non per
camminarci sopra come qualcuno ha fatto
non per dividerla come qualcun altro
fatto ma per fare dell'immagine delle
immagini che sono sempre in movimento
perchè alla fine quando mi fermo forse
sono statiche ma mentre le faccio si
muovono sempre un'altra cosa che mi
piace dipingere oltre a fare ce li a
fare nuvole io farei solo nuvole nella
mia vita è fare il fuoco e per fare
fuoco con l'acquarello che cosa si usa
si usa l'acqua fare il fuoco con l'acqua
è una di quelle cose quei paradossi che
tanto mi fanno pensare che sono sulla
strada giusta
cioè ho mille dubbi o quando faccio un
immagine ma quando faccio il fuoco
sono sicuro che sto facendo la cosa
giusta perché con la pittura si può fare
il fuoco con l'acqua ed è qualcosa che
ha a che fare con l'impossibile se
paragonato alla realtà però è quello che
vi giuro mi fa appunto stare bene quando
faccio le mie immagini un'altra cosa
la mia come dire la mia passione per un
certo tipo di immagini e fosse le
immagini che prediligo sono quelle che
non ci sono e quelle che non ci sono le
trovo spesso e volentieri nei libri di
poesia cioè quando la pagina bianca e il
testo scritto quel testo scritto è
l'immagine e la pagina bianca viene
investita dai miei pensieri
cioè dai pensieri del lettore ecco
quelle sono le immagini che io
sinceramente preferisco perché perché
sono pulitissime perché sono infinite e
ognuno ci può appunto mettere la propria
fantasia
la fantasia che è un arma ed è una
possibilità che tanti appunto ecco
dimenticano verso i dieci anni nel
passaggio tra le elementari e le scuole
medie e del ed è lì che invece perdiamo
delle possibilità perché io con la
fantasia
ovviamente
ci ho fatto un mestiere ed è un mestiere
che non è una mestiere che dico oggi
voglio fare questa immagine qui o che no
è un mestiere che prevede molta
disciplina e anche molto molto studio
diciamo che con le immagini e con la
fantasia
io sono come dire riuscito ad entrare in
una zona che amo moltissimo che è
un'altra vita è una seconda vita è
un'altra possibilità che nasce
soprattutto da un desiderio un desiderio
di un altro mondo che è fatto di
immagini che possono essere fatte
con l'acqua dove dove si può fare il
fuoco si può fare un fulmine dove si può
fare un veliero perché l'ho fatto
diventare prima un timbro e dove si può
anche fare una cartolina come questa
e si può anche dire anche se siamo in
questa situazione che mi sembra molto
chiara si può anche dire questo
grazie